[Music]
in the near future cash could become
obsolete and your phone could completely
replace your wallet mobile payments
which are already commonplace in
numerous countries worldwide are
steadily gaining traction in China's
biggest cities 92 percent of people use
WeChat pay or alipay the markets main
competitors and mobile payments are
accepted by restaurants retailers street
vendors and even taxis more broadly in
2018 the mobile money industry completed
1.3 billion dollars of transactions
daily across 90 countries this
underscores a shift toward a cashless
society dominated by electronic banking
and digital finance for physical
transactions like bartering are
virtually non-existent proponents for a
cashless system believe that digital
money increases convenience and could
reduce robbery and counterfeiting while
opponents argue that it endangers
privacy and hurts disadvantaged
communities that rely on cash and while
many of the long-term consequences of
cash lessness remain to be seen the
movement towards a cashless society
seems highly likely if not inevitable